he's one of the best-selling artists of
all time he's won 21 Grammy Awards
making him one of the most awarded
artists all time as well as the most
awarded artist for his age Time magazine
named him one of the hundred most
influential people in the world
his Kanye West and here are his 10 rules
for success I'm not going to sit inside
of a corporation for 20 years the time
is now the time is now to express and
for people to believe in themselves the
time is now for it to be okay to be
great
people in this world shun people for
being great for being a bright color for
standing out but the time is now to be
okay to be the greatest you when this
goes online or whatever it is it really
matters and it like really doesn't
matter what matters is you know the
people who are sparked by it and the
people who are like offended by it it
doesn't matter you you know like because
it's about motivating the doers and
anyone that wants to sit around and talk
they're doing too much time it taken too
much time talking good about it
instead of getting up off their ass and
following their dreams because I'm here
to follow my dreams you know and help
other people follow their dreams and
inspire people who are dreamers it's
crazy that we live in a world that if
you're super positive and super creative
that it's scary so what does that tell
you about the mentality of most people
if you're scared of like positivity and
creativity
do
and always know there's a way
take me home
be hungry
be awesome
Oh
everyone out there in TV world real
world whatever world you stay in needs
to know that I've never done a publicity
stunt in my life any time I went up and
spoke my mind where they put my career
in jeopardy or whatever someone
so-called said it was always what I
thought was the truth without my
greeting to a teleprompter or whatever
whatever I felt emotionally I don't
follow like rules of like you know
normal celebrity or what their publicist
tells them to say anything but I say
things the wrong way a lot of times my
intention is always positive and I want
to bring more things to the world I want
to help the world I want to make
people's lives easier I said if you guys
look at the same interview it's really
something extremely fearless for someone
in my position to do because most people
just like you know bow tie on a TV or
whatever bow down to these cameras like
I could care less about any of these
cameras in all honesty all I care about
is my family I care about protecting my
girl for Tara protecting my baby and
protecting my ideas and my dreams yes
I'm totally weird and I'm totally honest
and I'm totally inappropriate sometimes
and the thing is I you know for me to
say I wasn't a genius I would just be
lying to you and to myself okay so you
should be John Stephens yeah it was
Kanye West who said change to legend you
know the first person actually was a guy
named Jay IV who's also from Chicago and
his a friend of mine and Kanye's and
he's a poet and we working on Kanye's
album and Kanye was having me seeing all
these parts and a jiv was just like man
we're gonna have to call you the legend
cuz you know my voice is kind of
old-school I've always had an old soul
Kanye as I'm a should just call yourself
John Legend and I was like no that's
ridiculous you know of course Kanye's
got a new album called yeezus so he's
not afraid to say big bold things and
and you know maybe I'll just roll with
this whole John Legend thing and my kind
of ultimate deciding factor was let's
not not do it out of fear because
because you're afraid to call yourself
oh yeah let's not not doing because
because I'm afraid that it won't work
out like cuz people could laugh at you
if you don't have a good career and
you're going around calling yourself
legend you think you now live up to it I
think I'm working on it I'm on my way
okay please thank you please take a rap
on you right now me rapping right now a
dumpling wrapper this truck right foot
right on the bar guitars idea right here
bring it
hey mr. West my name is cam gray from
the 937 came to annihilate my king young
heavyweight primate young came racing in
front of Kanye I wish you would give me
a deal that's what I needed I swear my
whole life is I've been dreaming that's
what I got I feel it that's what I got I
made this happen last night I told my
homie this what happened I told him I'm
again at Kanye then we took it do a
written go read for high pressure never
like go far doesn't even do bars he
responds I was born in tennis even my
heart stays up in Ohio get my weed from
a few Cali be known that for a while
shake my style mother got a recipe see
I'm the best in the Midwest better
mention me yeah my name is Kara $120 D I
couldn't afford from a PC I'm not done
man I got my degree I got my life
together I got much together come on
dawg real give me a chance for me I
swear to god man swear to God
you be open to start off as like an
assistant man I'm down and start
anything I just want to learn you can
start somewhere man man
thank you very much to you thank you for
your charter and thank you very much
Johnny oh thanks taking the favor camera
gret camera great so many people are
just so obvious they don't even realize
that when they box me in or try to
verbally put me in some type of box will
put Donda in a box that they're really
showing their level of ignorance they're
putting themselves in a box and you know
people can write write write all they
want but what are people doing and if
there's anybody that's out there doing
they know how hard it is to actually do
and I'm like a motivation of the doers
if if everything I did failed which it
doesn't it actually succeeds but if
everything I did failed just the fact
that I'm willing to fail is an
inspiration people are so scared to lose
that they don't even try like one thing
that people can't say is they can't say
I'm not trying I'm not trying my hardest
and I'm not trying to do it the best way
that I know how what little information
I get I refuse to follow those rules
that society is set up in the way that
they control people with low self-esteem
with improper information with branding
with marketing I refuse to follow those
rules it's about truth it's about
information
it's about awesomeness and the only
luxury is time the time you spend with
your family that's the only luxury to
this concept of luxury is is improper to
me when I compare myself to Steve Jobs
or Walt Disney Howard Hughes David Stern
Michelangelo da Vinci Jesus or whatever
is I'm saying these are my heroes
these are people that I look up to this
is the type of impact I want to make on
the earth if I can make this type of
impact up to this point what can I do if
if you call Bob Iger and say yo give him
a shot if you call Oprah and say yo back
this kid let's just get this game this
kids kids were his parents were
educators he wants to educate he wants
to look at curriculums and say how do we
simplify that exactly what I did in
music I want to apply to product I want
to apply to education this is
what my company Donda is about there's a
series of theater people who like right
just negative comments they want to joke
around and say why is he still trying
you know if I see something I see
opportunity I'm gonna go for it
I'm here to crack the pavement and make
new grounds
you know sonically and in society
culturally we're not always in the
position that we want to be at we're
constantly growing we're constantly
making mistakes
because he's trying to express ourselves
are trying to actualize our dreams I
want to create something better for you
we have been limited it's bigger than
you know who I am even in this you know
in my presence living it's about you
know when I was on earth what did I do
to help I want people to think more I
want people to feel like it's ok to
create and follow what their dreams are
and not feel boxed in I want people to
feel like awesome is possible there's a
lack of creativity in every field cuz
people are afraid as an artist and in
this world we could do whatever we want
you know so you're gonna love me you're
gonna hate me but imma be me
thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know what you think of Kanye
West as an entrepreneur if you want to
leave a comment below I made this video
on Kanye because Jose Cruz asked me to
so if there's someone you'd like me to
make a top 10 list of leave it in the
comments below as well and I just might
make it
and of course believe thank you for
watching I'll see you soon